Oh witty but go down the slide or get
out of the way you think I even want to
feed your child my therapist told me I
need to force myself to go out and do
things to overcome my anxiety can we
move him please I think people would
think that he shouldn't be allowed at
water parks you gotta calm everybody
just so you know colleagues people with
anxiety should just stay home yeah I'm
trying to come out of my shell but dr.
Kyle Harris is worried about his place
at night get off my towel get off my
couch god damn it I seriously can't get
a minute of peace why is it the people
who don't have a Buddha box are always
flipping Buddha boxes off the heads of
people with anxiety I got news for you
Cartman
everyone has anxiety everyone gets
nervous everyone is afraid being around
people everyone has feelings faint
brothers stay home alone
and you know what they do don't get over
it and they stop being a piece of
everyone has anxiety yes oh my god I
know what I have to do now you're right
huh
you're right what no no what did I just
do should have just let him be on his
phone dude